distinguished speakers and fellow
researchers a very warm greeting to one
and all
my name is shrigary krishnakumar i am a
research intern at pine biotech
i am here to talk about my journey to
bioinformatics through omics logic
training platform
i completed my undergraduate degree in
forensic science from amity university
noida india
after completing my undergraduate degree
i joined pentagram discovery which
focuses on zebrafish as a research model
for drug screening and drug efficacy
studies
as a research assistant i had the
opportunity to work on several disease
models including parkinson's
huntington's pancreatic tumor and
diabetes to name a few
as i continued to work on these projects
i started coming across several research
articles that talked about the
applications of machine learning and
data science in zebrafish models
especially in the field of neuroscience
i got fascinated as i started learning
more and i soon realized that i wish to
work at the intersection of biomedical
science and computer science
but before pursuing my higher studies in
this field there were few factors that
were important to consider
one is that before pursuing an expensive
master's degree i wanted to network with
the peers in this field to know more
about the opportunities and scope of
this field secondly i wanted to work on
a hands-on research project to get an
idea of what it is like to work in this
field and finally i've always admired
the mentor-mentee relationship and
throughout my learning experience i
wanted to receive guidance from an
expert who's already working in this
field
and the only program that was available
at the intersection of all these three
factors were the omex logic research
fellowship program and i got enrolled
the initial months of my program were
devoted to training and so far i have
completed the following courses on
introduction to bioinformatics genomics
transcriptomics our coding course 2
introduction to data science and project
on modelling cancer precision medicine
and apart from my coursework learning
i'm also working on my research project
that aims to conduct transcriptomic
profiling of chlamydia pneumonia
infected coronary artery endothelial
cells to study their role in the
progression of atherosclerosis in
coronary artery disease patients
and as an intern at pine biotech i am
also responsible for creating blogs and
as a part of my work i recently had the
opportunity to write a blog on best
online courses on bioinformatics and
after reviewing several of these courses
i grew to admire the uniqueness of the
courses and project opportunities
offered by the omics logic learning
platform
here are some of the key highlights of
the program from the from my perspective
as a student from non-bioinformatics
background
first of all the library of asynchronous
learning material on topics
ranging from genomics to metagenomics
that takes you from the beginner level
to the advanced level
secondly there are numerous sample
projects that are sourced from high
impact research publications in the
field of oncology biotechnology
neuroscience agriculture and infectious
diseases
the weekly research fellowship meetings
where you can share your queries
research project updates and receive
expert feedback on how to progress
further is also my favorite
there is also an active peer community
consisting of enthusiastic faculties
students and researchers who are
learning and working on the research
problems that they are curious about
and finally the omics logic and fine
biotech team has been extremely
supportive right from the start of the
program and helped me during every step
of the program
to conclude i wish to say whether you
are a student a researcher or even if
you wish to be part of the citizen
science to contribute to the scientific
community through the use of
bioinformatics i would highly recommend
you to join the omics project learning
platform
would like to take this opportunity to
thank mr eliabrotsky dr mohad mazumdar
dr raghvendran lakshmi narayan mr ali
kha ray and ms bash there for being the
constant source of support during the
every step of the program thank you